Leo
Major was a French Canadian man born in 1921.
He probably didn’t think he was going to
be more of a hero than the average soldier
when he joined up with the Canadian Army at
the start of World War II—supposedly he
simply joined up because he wanted to show
his father, with whom he had a shaky relationship,
that he could do something to be proud of.
Major started his overseas tour in 1941, serving
in Le Regiment de la Chaudiere.
On D-Day, he was wounded by a grenade, resulting
in the partial loss of vision in his left
eye.
Major refused to be sent home, arguing that
he only needed one good eye to sight a rifle.
He was placed in the scout platoon and became
handy with his rifle, earning himself a reputation
as an excellent sniper.
In April 1945, Major’s regiment was approaching
the city of Zwolle.
His commanding officers asked for two volunteers
to do a reconnaissance run and report on the
number of German troops patrolling the city.
If possible, the volunteers were also asked
to get in contact with the Dutch resistance
as the Chaudiere regiment was to start firing
on the city the next day.
At the time, Zwolle had a population of around
50,000 people and it was likely that innocent
civilians would number among the casualties.
Along with his friend Willy Arseneault, Major
started to creep toward the city.
Willy was killed by German soldiers around
midnight after the pair ran across a roadblock.
Reportedly, Willy was able to kill his attacker
before dying himself.
Understandably angry, Major picked up his
friend’s machine gun and ran at the enemy,
killing two of the remaining German soldiers;
the rest fled in a vehicle.
Major continued on and soon ambushed a staff
vehicle and captured the German driver who
he had lead him to an officer drinking in
a nearby tavern.
He informed the officer that Canadian forces
would begin firing heavy artillery on the
city, resulting in the deaths of many German
soldiers and Zwolle civilians alike.
He didn’t mention that he was alone.
Afterwards, Major gave the man his gun back
and, with that seed of knowledge soon to be
spread throughout the German troops, he immediately
began running up and down the streets shooting
a machine gun and tossing grenades.
The grenades made a lot of noise, but he made
sure to place them where they wouldn’t cause
much damage to the town or its citizens.
In the early hours of the morning, he stumbled
upon a group of eight soldiers.
Though they pulled a gun on him, he killed
four and caused the rest to flee.
Major himself escaped the confrontation without
injury and only one regret: he later stated
he felt he should have killed all of them.
As he continued his campaign of terror throughout
the night, the German soldiers began to panic,
thinking a large body of Canadian forces were
attacking them.
By 4 a.m., the Germans had vanished.
An entire garrison—estimated to have been
made up of several hundred soldiers—had
been made so afraid of nothing more than a
single, one-eyed man that they fled the town.
The city of Zwolle had been liberated without
the need for the death of civilians or many
of the soldiers on both sides of the lines
that would have taken part in the messy battle.
Rather than fall asleep after running around
the city in the wee hours of morning avoiding
German gunfire and causing all kinds of mayhem,
Major enlisted the help of several Dutch civilians
to retrieve the body of his friend Willy.
Only after his friend’s body had been recovered
did Major report to his commanding officer
that there was “no enemy” in the city.
The Canadian army marched in to the sound
of cheers rather than gun shots.
For his actions at Zwolle, Major received
a Distinguished Conduct Medal.
If this wasn’t all enough, perhaps I should
mention that in 1944, a year before he liberated
Zwolle, at the Battle of Scheldt, Major captured
93 German soldiers by himself and led them
to waiting Canadian troops.
He and Willy were teamed up again on a reconnaissance
mission to find out what had happened to a
company of men that had seemingly disappeared.
Willy was sick, so Major went alone.
He soon found that the company he was looking
for had all managed to get themselves captured.
Rather than go back and report immediately,
Major was cold, so went into a nearby house
to warm up.
At this point, he saw a couple German soldiers
through a window and decided to capture them,
which he did.
With them presumably helping him lug his balls
of solid steal along the way, he had them
take him to their commanding officer, who
was among about 100 other German soldiers
at the time.
His offer was basically- surrender or you
die.
Of course, he’d then die too, but this plan
miraculously worked.
Why?
Because some nearby SS troops observed the
exchange and misinterpreted, thinking the
commanding officer and his men were surrendering.
Thus, the SS opened fire on both Major and
the German soldiers around him.
The Germans being fired upon decided surrendering
to Major was better than being killed by the
SS, so they went with him, with the SS hot
in pursuit, killing some of them along the
way.
All total, 93 Germans soldiers made it back
with him and became POWs.
For this amazing feat, Major was offered a
Distinguished Conduct Medal, but refused it
because he felt his commanding officer, Field
Marshall Montgomery, was “incompetent”
and that, “He had made an awful mistake.
I didn’t like him at all.”
Thus, he didn’t want to receive an award
from the Field Marshall’s hand.
Still not impressed?
How about how he won his second Distinguished
Conduct Medal, besides the one earned liberating
Zwolle, which would have been his second,
had he accepted the 1944 one.
The second one he chose to accept didn’t
come in WWII.
Rather, it was achieved during the Korean
War where he managed, in a lot of ways, to
top the other two, though this time with the
help of just under a couple dozen other people.
But I think you’ll soon agree, it was still
ridiculously amazing.
Around 40,000 Chinese soldiers had successfully
dislodged a large body of U.S. soldiers from
a key hill (Hill 335 to be exact).
Unable to retake the hill, Major and a small
group of other snipers were sent in.
There job was to sneak up onto the hill, in
the midst of all those Chinese soldiers, and
then open fire.
After doing this and throwing the Chinese
soldiers into a panic, rather than retreat,
Major had his men continue firing and managed
to do what thousands of U.S. troops had been
unable to do, re-take the hill.
Of course, the Chinese soon regrouped and
two divisions, totaling over 14,000 soldiers,
were sent to retake the hill from Major and
his tiny band of snipers (20 men total).
Again, rather than retreat as ordered, Major
and his band decided to hold the hill.
After three days of repeated attacks from
over ten thousand soldiers using every manner
of weaponry, reinforcements arrived and relieved
Major and his men, who had successfully held
the hill during that span.
I presume after being relieved and having
the relieving commanding officer perhaps tell
him it was madness to try and hold the hill
with so few men, Major most likely responded
with “Madness?
THIS IS SPARTA!!!!”